[Music]
after the jaw-dropping cliffhanger of
stranger things season 3 fans have been
waiting patiently to find out what's
next for 11 chief hopper and the rest of
the hawkins gang thankfully the show has
finally returned to netflix for its
fourth season as it reaches new levels
of terror thanks to its latest mystery
surrounding a horrifying new villain
but the heroes are scattered when the
season first kicks off with 11 will
byers his brother jonathan and his
mother joyce still living in california
after hopper's death at the end of
season three but the rest of the kids in
hawkins realize that something is
preying on the troubled teens in town
which leads them back to the upside down
the series has already been met with a
great reception from critics who have
praised the deeper horror tone of the
series though many complained about the
long run time of the episodes they all
clock in at over 1 hour each while
episode 7 the massacre at hawkins lab
pushes that to 1 hour and 38 minutes but
considering the new season introduces
its latest villain wekner it's
understandable why the duffer brothers
needed more time to establish everything
that's going on
many fans might be wondering why 11 gets
sidelined for most of the season while
she gets her powers back with dr brenner
and sam owens the bulk of 11's arc is
told through flashback sequences and
they're vital to the season not only do
they reveal what she went through in the
hawkins lab before season 1 but it all
builds to a shocking revelation in
episode 7 about one of the other
children that brenner experimented on
the younger version of 11 in the
flashbacks is a very lonely girl who's
shunned and bullied by the other
children in the lab and the season's
opening heavily implies that she kills
them all in a bloody rampage it's
revealed that her only friend was a
quiet orderly called peter ballard
played by harry potter alarm jaime
campbell bower although he helps 11 cope
with the trauma of being trapped in the
lab and how to deal with the other kids
it's hard not to be suspicious about his
intentions eventually the abuse 11
suffers alongside brenner's manipulation
of the lab overwhelms ballard and he
reveals his true identity as a son of
victor creole peter explains his
abilities has started to emerge when he
was a child and he discovered his
parents past sins by looking into their
minds although victor previously thought
it was a demon who was causing chaos in
the creel home it was actually his own
son he resented his parents for the way
they treated him it's true that peter
actually forced his family to live
through haunting visions of their worst
nightmares before he slaughtered his own
mother and his sister
that's a horrifying thought
unfortunately after victor was wrongly
convicted for the gruesome killings the
young boy was acquired by dr brenner and
he became the first candidate in his
experimental program yes peter is number
one the massacre at hawkins lab well
peter was responsible for that too as he
breaks down after years of being beaten
and downtrodden by brenner and his goons
but it gets worse peter's whole
backstory is a way of making audiences
understand the big bad of the season
wekner
on one hand it's relieving to know that
11 isn't actually a mass murderer this
entire time but on the other hand it
proves just how dangerous peter 1 really
is when 11 discovers that peter has
slaughtered the entire lab it quickly
turns into a telekinetic battle between
the two and it ends with 11 pinning him
to a wall and blasting him repeatedly
until he slowly disintegrates before
being thrown into a gate to the upside
down you can see where this is going
as the twisted villain falls through a
cosmic hellscape he gets hit several
times by the eerie red lightning that
constantly lights up the upside down and
the painful sharks transform him into a
grey fleshy version of himself although
it's not clear why his nose fell off or
how he started plugging himself into the
upside down using tentacles gross
basically eleven is responsible for
peter aka one becoming wekner that's
going to leave her with a lot of kills
since then wekner has amassed more power
by absorbing the trauma of the troubled
teens and hawkins it seems likely that
he wants to get revenge on eleven and
brenner before he makes his claim on the
rest of the world remember when peter 1
delivers a typical join me villain
speech he tempts 11 by saying they could
reshape the world how they see fit
because of their powers he probably
hasn't given up on that goal it's a
brilliant cliffhanger to end stranger
things season 4 volume 1 with will
victor creel learn the truth how is 11
going to defeat peter aka one aka wekner
it's going to be a long wait until
volume 2 arrives on july 1st
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv shows and movies are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]